de trouver les familles sains mais j'ai
pas j'ai pas eu le temps j'allais le
même type le mans non à la lgv est
réussi mais un certain nombre de mesures
que si j'étais tranquille en quoi alors
moi je suis dit non barbara ne va pas
depuis je ne l'en je n'aime pas te voir
des yeux babara voyons
babara la soirée soit réussie tu verras
et là j'ai pas le temps de faire passer
maintenant à l'omp à changer eux
qu'est ce que tu vas te m mais qu'est ce
que j'aime est hébergé ben je vais je
vais rester comme ça comme ça oui
méthanier de regarde-toi quoi ton
pantalon il faut chaud nous il faut mais
ça c'est rien j'ai un petit coup de
faire bien chaud inpact boule bien
humide et la la la la
comment dirais-je la fibre la fibre de
la poche
la fibre va resserrer une paix plus
excellents ufac mollkirch est relative
la patrouille retire la fibre c'est
connu banier oui je te parle
si toi mais elle ça m'ennuie de te dire
ça mais je m'en sens obligé c'est mon
devoir
daniel tu te dis que tu te laisses aller
je me laisse aller
tha ah oui tu étais savez ça je ne sais
pas d'où ça vient mais tu n'es plus
comme avant bat un ge qui traînait en
deux chambres pas rasé pas la vie mais
je prépare les petits déjeuners piale je
peux faire faire ma toilette après le
ménage parce que
je sais mon chéri je sais je sais tu es
très attentionné qu'est ce que tu veux
que je te dis tu te laisses aller bon tu
as été impeccable rasé très près tout
inonder d'after shave était alors
maintenant regarde toi daniel quoi
regarde moi qu'est-ce qu'il ya assez mon
col de chemise qui va pas gagner
oui tu ne te koop même plus les poils
des oreilles ah ah non ça c'est non
c'est non bliss
c'est uniquement en oublie parce que de
l'autre côté ça a été fait hier après
midi
peut-être mais c'est surtout un ensemble
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise tu
te laisses a levé sur tout le monde ne
pas prendre ça comme un reproche mais tu
manques de masculinité
je manque de masculinité oui oh que
c'est ennuyeux pas tant que voulait
faire un petit effort peut avoir tant de
charme quand tu veux as tu sais non non
je ne ne suis pas du tout mon genre très
séduisant au séduisant non quand même
non tu vois je me verrais dans la rue je
ne me suivrait pas idiot
allez je me sens j'ai pour le dur allez
je te suis